les touristes qui désertent peu à peu
l'île de la réunion l'épidémie de
choukouya se renforcent des chiffres
sont là pour le dire on compte
actuellement 15 mille nouveaux cas par
semaine loin donc et des précédents
bilans et selon la préfecture le pic de
l'épidémie n'est pas atteint edouard
baer jan et au marbre le virus du
chikungunya serait bien à lui seul
mortels à en croire le directeur de
l'hôpital de saint denis
un enfant de 10 ans mort le 13 janvier
dernier pourrait avoir succombé
directement à une piqûre de moustique
depuis le début de l'épidémie 26
personnes ont trouvé la mort sur l'île
mais jusqu alors le chikungunya
n'intervenait que comme facteurs
aggravants d'une autre maladie
du coup les autorités ont décidé
d'intensifier le combat contre la
prolifération de moustiques jusque dans
ces carcasses de voitures ce matin une
opération coup de poing a été organisée
sous l'oeil des caméras et de la police
objectif inciter la population à se
débarrasser de tout ce qui peut attirer
les moustiques porteurs du virus
vous avez plus dans la presse également
aujourd'hui
6 réunionnais sur dix qui sont touchés à
la réunion la situation sanitaire
s'aggrave quinze mille nouveaux cas
chaque semaine soit 50000 personnes
contaminées l'épidémie se propage
toujours dans l'océan indien après la
réunion les comores et les seychelles
c'est au tour de l'île maurice d'être
touché 15 habitants ont été atteints par
le redoutable chikungunya et selon le
ministère français de la santé cela
risque encore d'évoluer ce virus en fait
se propage par l'intermédiaire de
moustiques le moustique pique une
personne malade en piquant il
il aspire le sang de la personne malade
et pendant que le virus deux à trois
semaines après il va repiquer une autre
personne qui n'est pas malade et à ce
moment là il a ger ctt le virus signe
d'une situation tendue tous les
spectacles culturels sont annulés sur
l'île de la réunion
les autorités locales craignent
désormais que le tourisme premier
secteur économique ne soit lui aussi
touché